all right mike
yes mike uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally um
rochester new york and tell me about
your family do you have both your with
your parents as a kid
um my dad was in the army and i think
world war ii
when he came out he was so sick he had
to be placed in a v8
hospital in batavia new york
and he lived his life there and that's
where he passed away at
so as a child i was with my mom my mom
was the only
caretaker and uh she wasn't a very good
mother
um i had to take care of eight brothers
and eight sisters
at my young age at that time so 17 kids
seven no eight all together you know
totally yeah
total of eight yeah um it would have
been a total of nine but
my one brother died at an early age at
12 of leukemia
he developed leukemia and passed away um
i started smoking at seven years old
uh started drinking i'm heavily my dad
was an alcoholic
my mom we never could talk to her never
you know
associate with half the time um
then i got into well at that age
i was um seeking brought over guys who
c-cars was uncles and stuff
friends of the family and that's where
it all started at the age of seven
i started being molested by them and
uh it went on for a few years and
i kind of put up with her because uh
you know i think she was getting paid
for it you know to make money for the
food and stuff
and um and from there i got interested
in
i think that's where i think that's what
i made up my mind i was
i was gay because i didn't know at that
time what to do anything else but then
and i started liking younger boys in
school
and um i quit school at the early age
i didn't quote i just never went child
protective service
was always trying to get me i i lived
off the streets for a long time
how far are you in school i went to
fellow school i think i went to like um
fourth grade fifth grade yeah right
around there is when i didn't go in the
markets i ran away from home
and lived down the streets with
rochester
in rochester new york with other
homeless kids who was into the sex
scenes with older guys and
things like that and um i met a um
young young young kid about my age and
he was telling me about these
um well clients he had and i didn't know
what he meant by clients but he said you
know sex part of the clients they paid
real good money
so i started with him and he introduced
me some of these clients and
after a few years i didn't know that um
the clients was
actually judges um lawyers
da's you know things like that business
guys you know would pay for young boys
and uh it went on from there then
after i i got about 1718 i met a guy
um he took me to uh
little town where he owned a house and a
farm
and um he was a sax partner at that time
and uh he passed away after years after
i was with him a few
few years i started working at a muck
company
um at that time i was about 18 19.
i met this young another young youngster
who was
at the time mowing the lawn of the
property that we lived on
well we hooked up and that became my
partner for a long time
and we just go to um um
what he called um music um thing um
concerts and stuff a lot a lot of
concerts and stuff
and um then i after a while then i met
my wife my first wife
i met uh her name was jolie and
i met her walking down the trailer car
she was just a nice gown
at that time i was 19. and we met
you know i pulled over and talked to her
we met we got married shortly afterwards
um we was married for a month we got an
annaman
because my little friend came over and
she kind of
called us you know she didn't know what
was going on but she didn't like going
offline in the bedroom
of the house so she figures out
something going on
so she went and told the kids parents
and they prepared me to see him but we
seen each other you know he's knockout
we've seen each other anyhow and uh so
then i moved away
and my my second wife which was marianne
and she had four kids three boys and a
little girl
um that's when the second
incident started when oh we moved down
to florida
and i met a few friends i might prank
you matter of fact and um
we moved to florida um went um this
other guy
i met in medina in new york where i used
to live where we moved from
he was uh uh gay um
and he owned a lot of probably a lot of
money i got involved with him
paying most of my rent everything else
my wife thought i was out working at the
time
i was getting a lot of money from him
and um
then we moved to florida he moved us to
florida he
bought us a house on behind taylor park
and we lived there for a while
and uh my youngest boy got in a fight
with the neighbor kid
and that weekend my boys went away to a
friend's house
and somebody threw a multi cocktail
through the bedroom window and burn up
the house
at that time yeah went up the house so
we moved from there
and then you know i got drinking more
and drugging mars a lot of drugs
he's injured but that's no no excuse
what i did
and um i started fooling around with her
oldest boy
we started fooling around and then it
was he
then it was the next younger boy we
started fooling around
and then we used to hang out i used to
hang around with the gay bars in
clearwater florida
pro shop and stuff like that and
we got involved in these hustlers who
would be waiting at a vehicle for when
we came out to the gate bed joint
and pick us up well you know we took
them home
has sex with them and that went out for
a long time and we paid them you know we
paid for you know paid for having sex
with them
and then they got involved in robbing
the place these hustlers and they got
caught
and there was a new mayor was trying to
be mayor of clearwater
and they put up a sting operation they
came and arrested us
first time i got arrested did um it was
it was called the clearwater 27 or 28
and i was back in the 90s and it was on
you know on paper something else like
that
and um we all got to wrestle everybody
got probation for because they had money
i didn't have money so i went to prison
for 10 years
i got automatically prison sentence and
nobody else did they got two years
probation everybody was involved in that
and uh at that time there was bankers
well-known bankers involved did it and
stuff like that so that's a story that
you look up in clearwater
it's it's in there and then they dropped
the charge on me on that
so they went after my boys they figured
that they could get me for
a higher charge if they go for a
custodian
of a parent you know with the boys so
that's what they did
how old were the boys my boys was um
13 and 14 at the time and uh
they weren't seeing them for a long time
but then they got him to talk
and i admitted to everything went to
prison
from prison when i first got in prison i
was scared and uh but i was honestly
open with everybody
and they asked me what i was in for i
told him i never lied to any of the
inmates
anybody in that regards anybody i
figured if if this is the time for
my life to end it's gonna end here and i
didn't have no problem with prison
then i thought i was getting out and
they hit me with a jimmy rice case which
is a civil commitment center
and i went there for eight years intense
counseling
um you know she he you couldn't come out
of the place she was locked down
i was locked down for eight years and i
had to go to counseling all day long
everything else is tense counseling
and um i didn't think i was ever going
to get out there
because they said most people die you
know they never get out jimmy rice
and but um i had a lawyer jim jeanine
colin
from tampa was real good lawyer got done
two state doctors to come and see me for
like four years in a row
and they had approved to let me out and
both doctors finally after four years
approved i was
fit for society and i was a changed man
and that's where my life went but
there's a lot of names i cannot mention
because um new york i you know i don't
if i mention names
i don't know what could happen i mean
with me so
just protect myself sure but um all this
from child protective service i was
molested
i was a hustler and all that could be
proven by the reports in new york child
protective service and all that so
your interest in young young boys yes
lasted for how long um lasted for oh
since i was like 18 to well to
um up to eight years ago until i
realized
you know that there was an age they you
know they couldn't get
consent under 18 to really have sex
something else
when i first pursued it when i was
younger you know because what happened
to me i thought it was
i'll you know find it you know if i know
if they you know okay they know i never
forced anybody none
this was always you know but i used a
lot of like um
pot you know to get them high because
kids backed in like pot and alcohol
and served it with them and you know
they were okay to you know different sex
acts and stuff like that
and i thought i wasn't doing nothing
wrong at the time but i was really
hurting them
you know and not only did i hurt them i
hurt the generation on you know their
family and on and on
so you know i you know i went to
counseling and i found all this out you
know about me
so now yes i'm still gay um i still like
men but
it's older men my more my age or maybe a
little bit younger whatever
you know and i like to meet somebody
that you know don't mind what i did
you know don't you know it's not right
what i did but
i'm not giving this cute [ __ ] i did what
i did and it was wrong
and i learned that but i want somebody
who knows my background so we could go
ahead and you know and
live our lives you know the way we want
to live you know i mean do you feel
remorse over what you did yes i do very
much i live with it
every night every day and i feel much
because when i was locked up
my wife is a deaf mute uh she can't hear
talk she was living in an apartment
in saint petersburg florida it was a
roommate who was a deaf mute
um a teacher used to be a teacher who
was selling drugs out of high school he
got caught
so he got arrested and he was banned
from the school but a year after that
just recently in 2011 he was driving
through my wife's neighborhood we don't
know what he was doing over there
and just happened to go crazy and kicked
in the door and stabbed my wife to death
and her roommate and um he went on the
cops was trying to get him and then i
was it took an hour for him to get him
but he ran over 12 year old kid trying
to kill him he ran over
a porch for a neighbor woman trying to
you know hurt them
he went around the corner broke in a
motel and beat the old man old lady up
in
in the head with a hammer put them in
tensor care so he did a lot of damage
before they called him in an hour now
he's serving four life sentences
for but i feel bad because i
feel you know i have to live with that
because if i didn't do what i do i would
have been home with her maybe i could
have prevented that i could hear the guy
coming i could you know did something
you know to present that you know but
you know if her kids
hate me now because of it you know they
said you know if you would not they
would say you would have been home
you know things might have been
different so you know yeah i live with a
lot of guilt
but i'm learning you know i learned to
take one day at a time
to live with what i did you know to
to go through life do you do you feel
like what happened to you
as a young man is your young boy kind of
caused this i think that nobody is born
gay
nobody's born i don't think that i think
what happened in life but early
on in life you taught things and you
take those things and
you learn things and what you can make
out of it yeah i think what happened to
me when i was younger
built me up you know to you know because
you know i've never thought that i'm the
only one in my fam my family don't have
nothing to do with me my brother's up
because
you know i'm a you know i'm a sexual you
know sexual predator
you know and you know because of what i
did that i'm going to do with me so
you know i you know i lost a lot so i
have to live with it yeah you lost a lot
of friends
lost a lot of friends lost a lot of
family family and
um lost my mom when i was locked up me
my mom was
my mom didn't really you know after she
got older and she understood
what she did and what i did you know we
we talked and
you know she said she should have been a
better mother but
she didn't know how to be a better
mother
at the time because she was young my dad
my mom was like
14 or 15 when my my dad was older man
and uh and they got married like that is
back then you could get married to daddy
so she didn't know how to raise
you know how to take care of kids and
you know
my dad was sexually active with her and
they had kids you know every year almost
you know once
you know so she didn't really know how
to be a mother or how
nobody taught her not you know being a
kid herself
would have known a man you know she
didn't know yeah
what's your what's your biggest regret
my biggest regret is um
messing up those kids lives that ruined
their life forever
that and and and i hope they someday
could forgive me you know for what i did
you know i mean not forgave what i did
but just
you know like you know forgive me for
what i did you know
go on with their lives and have a family
and you know be okay you know
that's my biggest regret yeah what what
emotion do you deal with most
because emotionally well um
when i was is when all this went out and
everything else like that i was um
i developed uh i was diagnosed
apparently schizophrenic
i'm on my medication i take medication
every day
um i
the thing i really regret is to not
having a normal life
like some kids have you know grown up to
be
successful and you know you know when
you go to prison anything else you
you have to take any job you can get and
people talk down on you
and you go you know people see you and
they know you're sex offenders
they you know they just people nowadays
are very
rather than the community helping you
know
us to get up on our feet once we got the
education we have
to do it to help us do better you know
there's i mean sex offenders are um
known as the dirt of the dirt i mean a
murderer can murder somebody and live
next door to you without you even
knowing it
you know not have to register none but a
sex offender we pay for for the rest of
our lives
we gotta register we gotta you know we
gotta
you know make sure we don't go in places
where you know kids are at anything else
like that so we gotta be a lot of
careful a lot of jobs we can't get
good jobs we have to work whatever we
could get you know to
survive you know the rest of our lives
and what's the most important lesson
you've learned
most important lesson i learned is um
to um
when you feel that something ain't right
when you're younger
that somebody's taking advantage of it
somebody's touching you or something
go to somebody right away and that's
what i should have done i should have
went to somebody who would listen you
know who would listen
you know an officer or you know
something another doubt that
away from my family that maybe got me to
help at that time
and guide me through the right way but
you had your own mother and your mother
wasn't
no my mother was even at the time we
didn't talk to my mother
my mother was like you know she didn't
care how late he was out at night who we
was with
guys would bring us home and say he'd be
nice to him oh yeah thank you thank you
ass pick up
me the next day oh sure she didn't know
these guys you know i mean
so i was like you know no parenting law
no
guidance or nothing what's the craziest
escapade you've involved yourself in the
craziest thing i can say i did in my
life
was when i was in new york and i had two
vehicles at the time el camino
and a camaro pretty new both of them
i had a friend who was gay too
by my age he had a driver's license we
got in the car
after drinking all day we put my kids in
the car my wife's
kids you know the boys and um driving
down the back road racing everything
else like that
we came up over the hill and i landed my
camaro in the back of my el camino
and uh the el camino went towards that
canal was full of water
a piece of pipe held it from going over
they probably would have drowned it and
we went for the woods and
and we and we when we came to we had the
kids run over
the other side of a bridge because we
know we could get in trouble for having
kids you know
and the car was was driving crazies
there was a witness to it
and uh we uh got uh
arrested for dui both of us we went to
court but before we went to court
when the troopers took us to the
hospital to get blood work
they took it from him first and before
they got me a friend of mine heard it on
a monitor by a police monitor
that i was being taken there for blood
tests he came down to the hospital told
me to go to the bathroom
i went to the bathroom and i drank
visine at that he told me drink the
bottle of visine
i drank it and i did the blood test and
he showed up he's really drunk and i
showed up and i have no alcohol in my
system at all
so i walked away with that free uh no no
tickets are known
so visine does this yeah yeah that was
the crazy thing after the journey i said
am i gonna die drinking this stuff what
are you trying to get me to do you know
i mean
how much of your questionable behavior
was fueled by alcohol or drugs
i don't think alcohol yeah it through
that because because
the behavior was there for you know not
being taught right
but it just helped it just helped it's
just how can i say it just helped me be
more
comfortable and easier to do things what
i did than
otherwise that i would before like now
um
frank would tell you i know frankie for
years since the 80s
i'm very i'm when it comes to somebody
that i've that i know is gay
that i like i i won't go up and talk
tomorrow
or you know ask them you know if they
want to go out or you know anything or
they want to drink anything
i'm i'm like a shy person but um when
when i quit drinking after all this
happened back in the 90s i quit drinking
and drugging
i haven't touched a drink or a drug
since and i won't and i may want
nothing and um and i just
you know i it feels like i died inside
because a lot of people said that too to
know me because i'm not as
easygoing and friendly and outgoing like
i used to be you know i mean
so the alcohol did a lot of that for me
hit a lot of feelings and stuff
and the drugs yeah all right mike well
thank you so much for sharing your story
you're welcome and uh good luck with uh
staying on track and uh
[Music]
and i hope help you stay this way
i'm gonna have trouble i'm i'm fighting
it every day i'm going to try take one
day at a time is it still a battle for
you
no because i'm you know what i learned
in the
civil commitment center and um
what you know i paid attention to and
what i'm learning out here is that uh
every day gets easier every day gets you
just got to take it one day at a time
did the therapy help
yeah therapy helps a lot yeah therapy
helps a lot if if you
you know put yourself to it you know if
you just sit there and don't listen
don't pay attention you got to put
yourself to it you got to participate
and it helps i'm telling you it helps a
lot
it works very much they say sex
offenders can't be cured but
i'm telling you i don't have no desire
of any
young kids now anything else or that you
know if i
i have desires of older people now you
know
you know things like that so it's you
know it really works therapy does help
sexual predators and sexual offenders
that they really put to
apply themselves to it all right mike
well thank you so much for sharing your
story
you're welcome thank you thank you
you